sie haben ja gesagt war ein wunderbarer
[ __ ] ist ein wunderbarer hat er gesagt
[Musik]
das zdf möchte roberto blanco heute die
gelegenheit geben sich zu bedanken weil
sie ihm einen wunderbaren mega genannter
roberto blanco bitte gedanken ich
bedanke mich für diese wunderbare und
tolle geschmack was sie haben und soll
weitere und wünschen alles alles gute
sie war es gar nicht so schön wenn man
das wunderbar erscheint war also es war
so gemeint ein wunderbares und wenn ich
gesagt sind ein wunderbarer weißmann
wirbel nicht sauber sein also wieso also
darum sie wollen nicht daraus ein 1 1 1
2 wir machen sie haben ja gesagt war ein
wunderbarer kläger ist ein wunderbarer
hat er wunderbare menschen so ist
roberto blanco der erste name der ihnen
ein feld für gelungene integration
es ging ein traum nachdem sich da ein
andere bürger in der sendung in
unerträglicher weise abschätzig über
farbige menschen geäußert habe wohl ging
es mir gerade nicht nur so etwas zu
verurteilen sondern deutlich zu machen
die stimmung der menschen in unserem
land ist eine ganz andere und es gibt
viele viele menschen die seit vielen
jahren auch über farbige mitbürger
begeistert sind die kommt dass also das
was das dass ich plötzlich die leute
aufregt nur weil einer mal im fernsehen
nie gesagt hat mein gott war graf ich
nicht das ist es ich bin selber schwarze
[Musik]
leuten kann man sagen
aber nicht finde ist an die ganzen namen
für einen menschen der woche wollen wir
die deutschen also gut was schwarzer
sollen das gibt es eben jetzt was er
besonders gut kann vielen jahren ein fan
von ihm
ich hätte es gegeben sind bekennt sie
nicht weg weil ich zwei drei stücke von
ihm von roberto blanco puppenspieler von
mexiko wirklich meine jugend immer
gesund sein
aus dass er spielt kein edler
mitgebracht hatte und ebola und er meint
das ist nicht etwas was ja aber das was
andere bisschen spaß muss rein hören sie
sich vielleicht noch mal wirklich in uns
ganz ernst zu bleiben noch mal den arm
nehmen das war das ja alle mit dieser
mutter waren
dann gebe ich zurück
[Applaus]